This episode of Real Engineering is brought
to you by Brilliant, a problem solving website
that teaches you to think like an engineer.
If we were to define WW2 in just one technology,
the likely winner would be aerial bombing.
World War 1 revolved around stagnant and debilitating
trench warfare, that both sides sought to
avoid in future.
Tanks and planes arose as a way of breaking
enemy lines quickly and inflict damage.
The rate of technological progress for delivering
larger and more accurate bombs during world
war 2 was astronomical, but early in the war
the technology was still in its infancy.
The Germans relied heavily on the Stuka dive
bomber.
A short range bomber whos siren became a harbinger
of death on the battlefield.
It dived towards its target, planting it firmly
in its crosshairs, imparting its bomb with
the velocity it need to fly straight to the
target, before releasing and pulling up hard
to avoid a collision with the ground.
This procedure was so taxing on its pilot
that the Germans developed an automatic dive-flap
that would deploy even if the pilot had knock
themselves unconscious with g-force.
These tactics arose because bombing aiming
technology was so primitive, bomb sights were
rudimentary and required skilled operators.
Having to factor not only the speed and altitude
of the aircraft, but the terminal velocity
of the bomb and how it would be affected by
wind as it fell.
Bombing from high altitude, where the bombers
would be relatively safe from Flak, gave little
precision to target specific buildings.
This combined with poor navigation equipment
resulted in both sides devolving into carpet
bombing, causing massive loss of life to civilian
life, which did little to help either side
win a war.
We saw in a previous episode how much effort
Nazi cities put into anti-aircraft defences,
and similar efforts were made in Britain.
These tactics did not come cheap, losses were
high for both sides..
Barnes Wallis, an Aeronautical Engineer at
Vickers, saw the futility in these tactics
and set his focus on developing new technologies
to aid British bombers in destroying strategic
German positions.
This was nothing new.
Factories, oil storage and transportation
infrastructure were always primary targets,
but Barnes wanted to create a weapon capable
of destroying a target others deemed invulnerable.
Dams.
Dams posed a tantalizing target.
They supply hydroelectricity, provided water
for industry and the German population, and
the resulting deluge of water from the massive
reservoirs would cause damage much greater
than any bomb the Brit’s had at their disposal.
The Germans were not ignorant to the allure
the dams as a bombing target.
Attacks on dams had happened earlier in the
war, like the attack on the massive Italian
Tirso dam in Sardinia, which held back Europe’s
largest man-made lake and provided the Italian
island with a third of its electricity.
They attempted the raid in broad daylight
with 8 Swordfish floatplanes.
3 simply failed to find the target due to
terrible weather, and the rest were welcomed
with anti-aircraft fire, taking one of the
planes down.
The remaining 4 continued to the target and
dropped torpedoes which travelled underwater
to their target before exploding, but the
dam remained standing.
The bombs were simply not powerful enough
to blast through the heavy concrete of the
dam.
To make matters worse, all dams across Europe
would be protected by anti-torpedo netting
from this point on.
So a new method to deliver an enormous bomb
capable of taking down a structure this strong
was needed.
Wallis spent most of his time devising devices
to take on challenges like this, and took
several things into consideration when designing
his bombs.
Explosive pressures decay extremely quickly,
and thus to ensure damage to the structure
it must be as close as possible, pressure
waves propagate through denser mediums far
more efficiently, and thus explosions underground
or in water will be more powerful.
And finally, doubling the size of the bomb
does not result in twice the blast radius,
to increase the blast radius drastically would
require a drastically larger bomb.
His design ethos from here was simply.
Design the biggest bomb his planes could carry,
and have them detonate underground or in water
to maximise their effect even further.
He presented his ideas in a 1941 paper “A
Note on a Method of Attacking the Axis Powers”
with the primary focus on a 10 tonne earth
penetrating bomb, that would be dropped from
40,000 feet, this was the most powerful non-nuclear
bomb ever used until just last year, and 42
were dropped in the final year of the war
that helped cut German supplies to the front
line, by destroying viaducts and railways.
But Wallis is remembered for a different bomb.
The British government hired the Road Research
Laboratory, a civil engineering firm, to begin
experiments to find the smallest charge needed
to destroy the Mohne Dam.
They constructed several scale model dams,
and used abandoned dams in Wales to find their
answer.
They found that even a 10 tonne bomb exploding
50 feet from the dam would not destroy it,
but a 2 tonne bomb could do the job if it
was placed directly next to the face of the
dam.
With torpedo netting installed, this job required
precision that had not been seen before, and
the method that was devised would break all
convention.
Barnes decided the best course of action was
to create a skipping bomb, that would bounce
over the protective netting before sinking
next to the dam and exploding.
He concluded that the mines would have to
impact at less than 7 degrees in order to
skipp, and all subsequent bounces would also
have to be below 7 degrees to ensure the bomb
continued until momentum was lost.
The bomb would be given a backspin prior to
release in order to take advantage of the
Magnus effect, which is lift created by a
spinning body.
Spinning the bomb provided it stability, like
a bicycle wheel in motion.
Helping the bomb remain on a straight trajectory,
but the lift the spinning provided was far
more useful.
By adding lift the bomb’s trajectory gained
more horizontal motion, and it’s angle of
impact was reduced.
Both of which aid skipping, and allowed the
bomber to release the bomb sooner, giving
them additional time to escape the imminent
explosion.
Once submerged the remaining spin would then
help push the bomb forward ensuring it stayed
in close contact to the dam wall.
This wholly unconventional bomb posed some
design challenges.
Any spinning object needs to be precisely
balanced to prevent vibrations that could
potential break it, or interfere with it’s
operation.
To aid this, Barnes early spherical designs
were scrapped in favour of a drum which could
be more easily manufactured and balanced,
while also aiding with it’s release mechanism.
The bombs were fitting to Avro Lancasters,
which were modified to accommodate the bomb
. The bomb doors were removed to fit bomb,
which would protrude below the plane for the
duration of the flight.
The lower ventral guns were removed to reduce
drag, as the mission would be flown so low
to the ground that they would provide no protection
against fighters.
Two v-shaped mounting arms were then attached
with free-spinning disc mounts which would
mate with the support rings on either side
of the bomb.
An off the shelf motor, typically used to
power hydraulic pumps on submarines was used,
and connected to the bomb with a pulley.
Finally, to release the bomb Barnes needed
some way of unmating bomb from it’s spinning
mount.
This was done rather ingeniously.
These mounting arms were stabilised with a
tensioned wire, which kept them firmly mated
with the bomb.
When the bomb needed to be released, the tension
was released with a solenoid actuated grip.
Compressed springs would then force the arms
to swing outwards by just a couple of degrees,
enough to release the bomb
The bomb was now ready, but little time was
afforded to the crew that would man the planes
that would carry them.
A new special squadron was created specifically
for this mission, formed by some of the most
experienced pilots the RAF had to offer.
This experience would be needed, as the entire
mission would be flown at extremely low altitude
at night.
Navigators had to learn to navigate with limited
information, often little more than the bomb
aimers calling out landmarks they passed over.
To increase the time they had to train, their
Lancasters were fitted with blue plastic screens
to the windows to limit visibility and light
during the day.
After many test drops the crew were finally
informed of their target on the morning of
the attack on May 16th.
That night they would take off from RAF Scampton
in 3 waves with a total of 19 aircraft.
Little would go smoothly from here.
The first of the planes was lost just an hour
into the mission, when it strayed off course
over the heavily defended Texal Island off
the Northern coast of the Netherlands.
Two planes collided with power lines and cables
as they flew low over the dutch and german
countryside.
Another plane flew so low as it crossed the
North Sea, that the low slung bomb collided
with a wave, dislodging it and forcing it’s
crew to return to base, followed shortly after
by another plane badly damaged by Flak.
At this point the entire first wave of planes
had failed their mission, but others were
finally reaching their target.
Gibson, the commander of the squadron, was
the first to arrive flying at 370 km/h just
60 ft from the water, he successfully dropped
his bomb which bounced three times before
sinking and exploding, sending a gigantic
spout of water above the dam, but it had sunk
too short of the dam.
On the following run a bomb bounced over the
dam and destroyed the powerhouse at its base,
while the Lancaster that carried it crashed
into flames after being struck by flak.
Gibson at this point circled back around to
act as a decoy, for Henry Young whos bomb
veered off towards the banks of the reservoir.
On the fourth try the squadron finally got
a direct hit, but another blow was needed
to collapse the dam, which came shortly after
as Gibson and Micky Martin flew decoy runs
alongside Maltby who scored a direct hit on
the already crumbling dam, sending 330 million
tonnes of water into the valleys below.
With their first target down, the 1st wave
continued on to Eder dam with 3 bombs left,
which was all they needed.
After two unsuccessful attempts, where one
bomb damaged the plane that was dropping it,
Knight’s Lancaster came in at the perfect
speed and altitude, releasing his bomb before
quickly pulling hard to avoid the 300 ft hill
directly behind the dam.
The first wave were now out of bombs and made
their journey home, but this leg was just
as dangerous, as the already damaged plane
was shot down soon after.
2 more lancasters would also be brought down
by flak on their return leg
The third wave lost two planes before reaching
their newly assigned target.
One strayed over the city of Hamm and was
gunned down by anti-aircraft guns, another
was lost over the Netherlands.
What remained mounted an unsuccessful attack
on the Sorpe dam, before returning to base.
In all the British lost 8 Lancasters in the
raid, killing 53 men, while another 3 who
managed to survive their crashes were taken
prisoner.
But the damage inflicted on the Germans was
far greater.
The resulting floods wreaked havoc on the
Ruhr valley, every bridge downstream for 45
kilometres was destroyed.
10 factories were destroyed and a further
100 were damaged.
Mines were flooded, and an estimated 400,000
tonnes of coal production was lost.
Acres of farmland were wiped out, and over
1500 people died in the resulting floods.
All this damage with just 19 aircraft, this
was precision that had not been seen before.
However, some have questioned whether the
raids were worth this loss in life.
Many of the people killed in the floods were
prisoners of war in forced labour, and others
are quick to dismiss this raid as a failure,
because the Germans recovered so quickly.
Taking just 5 months to repair the dams, in
time to ensure the reservoirs would fill for
the following summer.
But these people seem to ignore the immense
amount of resources that had to be diverted
to repair the dams.
They were repaired quickly precisely because
they were so vital to the German war effort,
that it was worth shifting thousands of works
and materials away from the front lines.
D-Day, which would come just a year after
this raid, could have gone very differently
if those resources had instead gone on to
fortify the beaches of France even further.
These 19 bombers, pound for pound, did more
damage to the German war effort than any other
British air raid thanks to the precision they
had been engineered to achieve, and precision
would become the focus of many of the wars
greatest engineers once the war had ended,
after all the Moon was much further away than
any previous target.
Once again, for this kind of topic a smooth
segue isn’t appropriate, but videos like
this would not be possible without Brilliant.
My goal for this project has always been to
inspire the next generation of engineers.
Brilliant is the perfect partner for this
channel because their courses are designed
to educate you from knowing nothing to having
a deep understanding of a topic.
Perhaps you feel like you could brush up on
your statistics skills, a valuable analytical
tool that help you academically and in your
everyday life.
This course on statistics guides you through
problems that are broken into digestible sections
with fun problems to test your knowledge along
the way, allowing you to see the pattern in
complicated data.
This is just one of many courses on Brilliant,
with more courses due to released soon on
things like automotive engineering and Python
Coding.
If I have inspired you and you want to educate
yourself, then go to brilliant.org/RealEngineering
and sign up for free.And the first 73 people
that go to that link will get 20% off the
annual Premium subscription.
As always thanks for watching and thank you
to all my Patreon supporters.
If you would like to see more from me the
links to my instagram, twitter, subreddit
and discord server are below.